Saka gets sandwiched backa boy slips it to PO
a tap for zaka he fires away a juicy [Music]
rebound Carlo flips the puck up the boards
Addison over to Benning and a kick by Swan
Addison Jacob McDonald sails
it in forward takes the
hit harlo indirect to Matt ptra who's between
Marsh and Heinen Marsh shot gloved by McKenzie
Blackwood in tight space grin can't control
Anthony duclair sends zerland ahead and swan
makes the save out of his crease it wasn't a bad
Try by poso but you're in that dangerous area you
know 5et inside the offensive blue line on your
back and when he gets picked off he battles back
this is where you don't want to turn the puck over
turn the puck over and it works nicely for San
Jose they're in a line change but they're coming
off that bench thinking pucks pucks available they
got a little something off that Rush themselves
quick shot by zerland for Swan to take it up high
brandland shot from aak and Duke Clair follows and
swayan is [Music] busy Anthony duclair
has scored five goals in his last five
games against the Bruins now if memory
serves me correct wasn't he on the Florida
[Music]
panther grin against Coy grin wins the
face off to okuk and a tip in front is
saved red line to POS knock a backand to
De Bros centering pass went off the apron
kachuck tips to declare he fires on San
and grizzli the Pu first n Go Sturm off
the boards everon shot deflected on the
way through and San makes the [Applause] stop
Jack back to Patra pass knock forber walks in
and misses the goal Funk where you give it up a
ton of goals they had a real nice shift at the
end of the period to set up this chance here by
forbert right off the post cross bar High glove
side One Touch Maran ridden off by
huk Patra with the turnover and hiend
scores good pursuit of the puck and San
Jose coughs it up does Brad marshan drag
his leg and his left skate long enough
for that puck to get completely in the
offensive zone it sure looks like it does
when you stop it right there but let's
finish the play first padra makes a nice
play protects it as best he can and then
makes it neat little backhand feed and hind
thinking shot love the shot mentality you
know he's almost at the bot zaka in traffic
Maran takes it to safety maoy pass knock
Maran a great save by Blackwood play in
possession of the offensive zone not the
clean entry but there's that second effort
Marsh Wis gets it on his back end away from
the stick check of the penalty killer now you
take maintain possession back to Center to keep
possession a touch pass for shaton Kirk launches
a two onone and a glove save denying ptra three
on three in overtime it's all about possession a
four on four during regulation time is the same
concept possessed the puck and the Bruins had it
the entire time even when Padre on the initial
Rush had a wrap it around the boards it was a nice
pinch down wraps it around D Rus bounces it to the
Blue Line de Brusque scores poock to zaka to Jake
to brosque and the throws are a command up two Z
gold sto with the dump in that Carlo uses his p
a forber for with a second effort to get it to De
brusk I like what de brusk is Jack he's down low
as an outlet for the left defenseman he doesn't
have a direct pass so he goes with the high lob
and now the Bruins are able to get to that puck
Bok first nice little touch pass by Carlo and then
that nice support do is in a good spot to be open
and get that short little pass and that opens Coy
Finds Frederick he tosses the puck to space Mario
feraro Frederick Steals and it's loose beer the
quick re-entry good job by L to stay on side yes
gymnastics brandlin closes and a save a save on
the rebound by Swan game got a couple of goals
that two nothing lead Ra's get a little time and
space so he lets that shot go rebound comes right
back out before the Bruins can for 12 at the dot
for Charlie Cole FR FR checked by duclair Carlo
an offering van re dke to [Applause] Cole B reke
breaking with makoy makoy a shooting angle and
blocker stop by Blackwood Staples Ferraro into the
boards Luke cing erson closes and Swan shuts the
door kak loce hurdle Dodges to brus hurdle
Maneuvers and tries the short side and a flip
on the rebound through the slot a little
unhappy there makes great play to keep it
in and then your teammate throws it back out
of his own poock wiggle and zaka [Applause]
scores Poo's ability to freeze Defenders is
paralyzing to an opponent FS of the five on
three kill nice little regroup this is the
the way they like to enter the Zone nice
little move to the outside San Jose doesn't
defend the middle ice and it's basically just
a simple give and go between those two players
and that's a nice Finish By Zach simple little
move get to the back end where I got tons of
Leverage Rin gets mashed and taken down by
makoy and makavo is going to ride that howy
horse and swing and makes a brilliant glove
save grin off hle skate makoy to Lind Holm a
fly pattern for poso and McKenzie Blackwood well
out of its crease the Bruins break their three
game losing streak with a 30 win over San Jose